[Musique]
est ce que vous trouvez jolie
comme si je me trouvais à 4 ça ne
m'intéresse pas je sais pas il faut
demander sa muse et demi qui mentionne
jacques ça qui compte le matin qu'est ce
que je souhaite
vous regarder dans la glace longtemps
oui bien sûr une bonne demi heure
vous
je me considère comme un nouveau là
c'est le culte de la beauté à tout prix
il faut la chercher par tous les moyens
c'est parce qu'il ya plus important
mais pour pas mal de filles c'est assez
important pour vous c'est important ça
une part d'importance que ces bâtiments
traque aux adjoints certaine caste
sociale ça fait marcher tous les
produits d'été et cetera je veux dire
scandaleux est-ce que tu sortirait sans
maquillage et surtout pas ça c'est
impossible pourquoi
je me sentirais tout nu
[Musique]
je crois que tu es pour le maquillage de
garçon curieux
oui ça réduirait un petit peu
l'inégalité qui entre les filles et
garçons présente jour défie par exemple
des mannequins grimés alors que les
hommes restent ou naturel s'est passé
pas normal
une si belle ou une fille intelligente
je préfère une fille intelligente
j'aime pas les poupées une fille ça va
être autre chose que sa salle où être
autre chose que couche toi là sois belle
et tais toi c'est je t'aime
je t'aime je
t'aime
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous pensez des publicités à
la télévision des journaux dans lesquels
on ne voit que des jolies femmes à moi
je trouve ça particulièrement scandaleux
en face comme je canalise encore plus
c'est voir des journaux enfin ça
m'embête de citer des noms dans lesquels
on on parle de femmes qui essaient de se
libérer des membres de leur émancipation
puis la page d'après ya pas la publicité
tapageuse ou encore la publicité sublime
halle enfin au moins essayer de faire
apparaître le sexe et où quelque chose
de violent fin pour que ça marche il est
en plus de ça c'est faire envier aux
femmes qui n'ont pas forcément qu'ils
sont pas qui ne se trouve pas forcément
joli faire envier la beauté faire envier
alors la beauté ça s'exprime par acheter
une jupe à la mode ou acheter des bottes
à la mode il c'est aberrant croyez que
la beauté
est relié à un système capitaliste
c'est ça le oui disons bonjour enfin
c'est toute une idéologie c'est un peu
le bas c'est ça c'est un fameux objet
c'est la femme qui doit être belle pense
pas trop bonne couche toi là car tes
cuisses et cetera quant aux salades pour
passer un peu plus loin
[Musique]
m
mais qui sont ces mannequins qui mesure
tout plus d'un mètre 70 sont elles
uniquement des symboles de la beauté ou
comme léonie son talent au delà
d'apparence un coeur et un esprit
[Musique]
je suis pas que mannequin je fais
d'autres choses je fais du tissage fait
des tas de choses parce que justement la
profession de la beauté c'est
j'aime pas tellement à 15 ans vous
trouviez belle aux non pas du tout
comment vous étiez à 15 ans j'étais
grande comme ça c'est à dire un mètre 84
g/t j'étais complexée alors évidemment
je me trouvais pas belle et maintenant
vous vous trouvez balle maintenant oui
oui je crois que je suis belle
pourquoi vous n'avez plus de cheveux sur
la tête parce que je me suis rasé
pourquoi
je suis rasé parce que j'ai été ordonnée
nonne bouddhiste zen et
à cette occasion on peut se raser les
cheveux
on peut ou on n'est pas obligé moi
j'avais envie de le faire alors je les
fais et puis comme je me sens bien je
reste comme ça
léonie en 1925 n'aurait eu aucun succès
les yeux sur son passage ne se serait
pas attardé trop grande trop mince ces
zapa aurait été trop petit les canons de
la beauté eux aussi au cours des âges se
sont modifiés
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu penses de la chirurgie
esthétique
ça peut être bien pour les gens qui ont
des longs nez ou fée des dents qui quand
après le bifteck ou quelque chose comme
ça mais enfin
j'aurais peur de fin pour moi j'aurais
peur de me faire ce serait une
catastrophe après l'obsession de la
silhouette est très importante chez la
jeune fille alors que faut-il le redire
et bien la silhouette dépend bien sûr du
squelette vendeurs capital musculaire
qu'il faut développer pour la
gymnastique le sport la danse et de
recouvrement de grèce
la cresse deux compartiments une grèce
disant métaboliques qui va et vient avec
le régime je mange gros si je mange moi
je diminue harmonieusement jeux gonflés
dégonfle puis il ya cette fameuse grèce
programmée par la génétique
j'ai des boules et entre 13 et 18 ans je
vais les remplir et je ne pourrai plus
jamais les faire maigrir complètement je
pourrais mincir mais ces boules
restaurant mais bon ce sont la culotte
de cheval par exemple c'est les poches
sous les yeux le double menton la boule
au dessus des saints la boule entre les
cuisses lapugnoy l'extérieur des cuisses
de grosses nous l'accrochage
à
voir s'est affolé d'esthétique du corps
j'aimerais que l'esprit et l'âme se
développe en même temps c'est très
dangereux d'avoir une religion entre
guillemets basée uniquement sur la
beauté du corps cela ne veut rien et le
nez ça va avec la figure savait et il
est allé dramatique de voir de temps en
temps parce que bon qu'on ne les ont
corrigé avec bonheur devant dans cet
état pire ces femmes payant je n'ai
rétréci en prise de courant qui leur
donne c'est un air un peu mutins
parisien mais qu'il les prive
d'expression l'impression qu'elle
n'envisage trop bref s'est passé quelque
chose car raboter partie la personnalité
en même temps que le bout du nez à la
laideur au naturel ça n'existe pas il
faut vraiment avoir eu un un accident ou
enfin quelque chose qu'on ait d'anormal
pour être laid il n'y a pas de plus et
le moins bon en fait quand on est les
gens bosser les gens qui sont eux mêmes
je trouve
il ya des gens qui ont un lieu qui n'est
pas beau qui ont un oeil de travers et
moi je peux très bien les trouver
[Musique]
les demoiselles vous qui vous croyez led
ce soir regardez vous dans un miroir
avec une pensée pour ses derniers mots
de léonie et d'isabelle
[Musique]